i was driving down the street
saw a prostitute
ask her how much he said 300 i'll do
anything you want i said [ __ ] paint my
house
because when you got a career there
ain't enough time in the day there ain't
enough time
you got a career you look at your watch
time just flies like god damn whoa
it's 5
damn i gotta come in early tomorrow work
on my project
because there ain't enough time when you
got a career
when you got a job
there's too much time
that's why you look at your watch like
ah [ __ ] 908.
you don't even trust the time when you
got a job to be like what time you got
what time you got
what time you got what time you got what
time you got
9 15 whoever got the latest time
is the right time you got the right time
you got the right time
you ever played a time game with
yourself at work
you ever played a time game where you go
i'm not gonna look at my watch
for two hours
i'm gonna sit here and scrape these
shrimp
scrape scrape scrape scrape scrape scrap
scrap scrap scrape scrape scrape scrap
scrub scrub scratch scratch scratch
squash scratch scrape scrape okay hours
pass
maybe i should look
and feel good
nah [ __ ] that i'm gonna wait a whole
another hour
squeeze scrape scrape squeeze scrape
squeeze squeeze scratch goes
great
all right two hours pass
time to look and feel good about myself
and you look
[ __ ] 15 minutes
you ever been so miserable at work that
you spend extra time just sitting on the
toilet
you don't even have your pants down
you're just like
i hate this [ __ ] job
i hate it
people around you taking smelly shits
they don't even phase you you're like
i'll give a [ __ ]
you keep [ __ ] cause i ain't quitting
a lot of good movies out dead presidents
you know
vampires [ __ ] a lot of cool [ __ ] a lot
of black movies you know it's [ __ ] up
there's no good black porno
a white porno flick is a real porno
flick got actors and actresses and a
plot even has extras
people walking around they're not even
[ __ ] just picking up [ __ ] and leave
yeah you ever see a black porno flick
there's a sorry [ __ ] on her first of all
they film them on view masters right
[Applause]
there's no actors no actresses just a
bunch of naked black people sitting in a
hotel room looking at a shitty camera
going is it on
is it on
well give him money i want my money i
[ __ ] it but i better get paid all right
you watch a black porno flick you always
see old out of work black actors too you
like ain't that the guy from what's
happening
ain't that the brother from barney
miller that's him
you know those white guys got good white
guys got good dirty magazines white guys
have playboy and penthouse and hustler
you know what brothers got players
magazine
the lowest dirtiest nastiest magazine on
the face of the earth the pictures
aren't even in focus that's how bad it
is okay just a bunch of pictures of
black girls sitting on the toilet right
and every time you like you turn it the
girl's like no
stop
close the door
close the door damn it
if you get playboy the girls are poles
all nice and sexy they got the pumps on
fishnets ass all out
and [ __ ] has combed
it's like pussy's got a perm
you get players and girls all mad cause
they're only getting ten dollars
then pippa's taking eight
they all mad
[ __ ] got dandruff
and a bald spot
don't no don't no don't know a lot of
women here that's cool like women
mother's a woman that helps you know
what's bug like whenever my female
friends start talking about you know my
boyfriend's crazy i didn't know he was
crazy i didn't know he was out of his
mind he just flipped
women if you want to know if your man is
crazy or not just check out his
relationship with his mother so all you
got to do check out his relationship
with his mother because he's like hey
mom [ __ ] you kiss my ass i'll get [ __ ]
out put this foot up your ass
if he's like that then you're next
late to school late in the work
so
women women women women women women
i don't know man how do you get the most
[ __ ] you learn about one thing you learn
about women men women don't like nice
guys say they do
dumb
they got to have an [ __ ] first
every woman goes through an [ __ ]
phase i gotta go with ike then mike
that's right you know what's bad if
you're a nice guy like me you always get
women after they've been out with an
[ __ ] so now you got to be their
boyfriend and a psychiatrist
to help them get over this psycho that's
right for every 20 minutes of [ __ ]
three hours of therapy
you know it's while it starts the
childhood starts to child little girls
like little bad boys like little boy
gives a little girl valentine's day card
she don't want him
she don't want nothing to do with him
she wants a little boy to just punch her
in the back and ran down the hall
oh i love him
he's so cute
then you grow up and you marry that same
little boy and next thing you know
you're an oprah going i don't know what
i did to deserve this
it just ain't right
but yo you picked that man you chose
that man you know you could have had
nice boy roy but you picked ass with
mcgee
oprah i love ass whoop he's a good man
in between after but he reads poetry
and violets are blue rose of the red
time to kick a [ __ ] in the head
you know what they say there's no reason
to ever hit a woman
she
she is a reason to hit everybody just
don't do it she's a reason to kick an
old man down and fly the stairs
just don't do it ain't nobody above her
[ __ ]
okay anybody can give you a reason to
hit and women know this for a fact women
i don't even men don't even got bad
women know this but ain't nothing more
crazy nothing more out of control
nothing more likely to embarrass you in
a [ __ ] restaurant than a woman that
knows you ain't gonna hit her
when a woman is with a man she knows a
hundred percent ain't gonna hit a whoa
she can't wait for him to do something
wrong
so she can yell at him like a little boy
what the [ __ ] you gonna do kiss my ass i
don't care where we are just kiss my
your punk your punk ass [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you
and the man's like how the [ __ ] we get
here
[Applause]
i tell you how you got there you got to
argue with your woman and went too far
and that was it
and women you know you can go too far
you can't guess you can go too [ __ ]
far
i'm a man and if i'm having an argument
with a man that's bigger than me i know
there's a zone i don't go into
okay
this is a zone i don't [ __ ] with okay
and women you could go to women they'll
go at you well they don't give a [ __ ]
they'll
then she say something didn't they say
the wrong things like that's why your
mama's a [ __ ]
[Music]
and she know she went too far
then she braces herself for the hit like
then the hypno comes like oh i got him
now you little big [ __ ] kiss
fire
yeah a little dick [ __ ] yeah i
don't give a [ __ ] yeah i [ __ ] all your
friends that's right yeah yeah i did
that yeah i was tossing salads child
yeah don't don't think don't leave it
don't think it's cool to hit women i
ain't on that [ __ ] now i know y'all
don't think that's cool i've never hit a
woman in my life i would never hit a
woman i ain't on that [ __ ] i would never
ever hit a woman in my life never
[Applause]
that ain't cool
i would never hit a woman nah but i'll
shake the [ __ ] out of one what i thought
was wrong with you
you crazy woman
i'll kill you girl
what the [ __ ] you tossing salads [ __ ]
are you crazy are you a [ __ ] nut shut
the [ __ ] up shut the [ __ ] up shut up
i'll let go when you shut up girl i'll
shake this weed about your head i don't
give a [ __ ] shut up
shut the [ __ ] up
i'm gonna let go and you're gonna you're
gonna sit down there you're gonna
[ __ ] eat your food and we're gonna
argue when we get home all right i don't
wanna hear no [ __ ] you better [ __ ]
eat your [ __ ] food and we're gonna
argue when we get home okay okay okay
i'm gonna let go up in and out of here
[ __ ]
[Applause]
problem
but
let me tell you right now the number one
reason people hate america the number
one reason is because of our religion
americans worship money
we worship money separate god from
school separate god from work separate
god from government but on your money it
says in god we trust
all my life i've been looking for god
and he's right in my pocket
americans worship money and we all go to
the same church the church at atm
everywhere you look there's a new branch
popping up
reminding you about how much money you
got or how much money you don't got and
if you got less than twenty dollars the
machine won't even talk to you
the machine's like you better go see a
teller
you ever gonna tell him trying to take
out eight dollars and fifty cent
oh it's disgusting
oh man you gotta wait on that long ass
line
people doing real transactions in front
of you you get up to the [ __ ] front
you fill out your form 850.
the [ __ ] teller looks at it she look
at you she looks at the [ __ ] she don't
even take the money out the drawer she
take it out a pocket
[Applause]
drugs are illegal
but atm machines are open 24 hours a day
24 hours a day for who
who the [ __ ] is it open for have you
ever taken out three hundred dollars at
four o'clock in the morning for
something positive
[ __ ] when you press that machine at four
o'clock in the morning i think a
psychiatrist should pop up on the screen
and go come on man
save your money man
don't buy drugs buy some rims
they spin it [ __ ] they spill it
they spill it [ __ ] they spill
don't know i like older women i'm in the
older women they're not
you know
you know not wheezy jefferson old
[Applause]
just older than me
cause young girls are full of [ __ ]
they like what they like so i wanted to
be this tall one's hair to be like this
one's eyes to be like this i'm going the
wall like this talk like this work here
all this [ __ ] i got nothing to do
with head here
now you get an older woman you got an
older woman single she's like hey i just
want a man
he got a dick and a job i'm happy
[Applause]
you know what you know what else older
women cook
all the women will cook you up some [ __ ]
all the women know the power of the pop
they will make you some young girl can't
make nothing reservation
[Applause]
all the women know the power of the pot
so they got all these shows on tv oprah
and sally jesse and all this [ __ ]
telling women how to get a man all these
books how to get a man you're women you
want to get a man that's what you do you
put a pot on a stove every day at six
o'clock a man will show up to that puck
[Applause]
yo fellas in my line
[Applause]
hell no
a pot on a stove every day not once a
week not twice a week every [ __ ] day
at six o'clock a man meant from miles
around that you have never met who shot
to that pot
but i got all this [ __ ] how to get a man
you dress like this and do your hair
like this and walk like this and talk
like this and sexist and sex that
anybody can suck a dick
[Applause]
but gravy's a whole nother story
[Applause]
but i would take a sweet potato pie over
a big ass any day
i will drop kick a girlfriend with a
banana pudding
ice cold banana putting this in the
refrigerator all night get your ass
[Applause]
that's right it's damn near impossible
for a man to turn down sex it's
for a man to turn down sexy we can stop
chasing it
and even that requires some rehab
but it's hard for a man to stop whoa
return what if it chases us we can't run
that fast
they're gonna catch us we're like
ah [ __ ]
pull the hands straight he got me got me
got me
you can't run that fast
see it's easy for women to turn down sex
it ain't [ __ ] for y'all to turn down sex
it ain't no thing for y'all to turn down
sex you're like how come you i can't you
turn it down i do it all the time i do
it all the time why can't you say no i
say no see it's easy for y'all you know
why because every woman in here ever
since she was 13 every guy you met's
been trying to [ __ ] you
that's right
women are offered dick every day
every woman in here gets off a dick at
least three times a week
three times a day [ __ ]
that's right every time a man's being
nice to you all he's doing is offering
dick that's all it is
it's all it is
that's all it is uh oh oh can i get that
for you how about some dick
[Applause]
oh could i help you with that can i help
you some dick
do you need some dick
nobody offers us [ __ ] we got to fend for
ourselves
we can't believe it we get off and we're
like damn that's my lucky day
i'm 21 i live at home i gotta move out i
have to move out because everybody in my
neighborhood nobody ever moves out i
have friends that are 28 years old and
live at home but this is pathetic
there's nothing more pathetic than a 28
year old man that lives at home only one
thing and that's any woman willing to
sneak into his room
so once you pay taxes you shouldn't have
to tiptoe past anybody
and i live at home and my mother likes
to clean up my room
and whenever my mother cleans up my room
she always takes out all my dirty
magazines
whenever your mother takes you dirty
magazines you can't say anything about
it if she don't say nothing you don't
say nothing
okay to play it off like they were never
there in the first place
you're sitting there eating breakfast
eating breakfast with your mother and
there's like attention at the breakfast
table because you're not like her little
baby anymore you're like some pervert
she's giving birth to
so you try to strike up any kind of
conversation you know like ma have you
seen my baseball glove your mother goes
well maybe you left it in the penthouse
sometimes you don't find out until it's
like too late it's like three o'clock in
the morning you need your book before
you go to bed right
you look around so you have to search
the whole house for any picture with a
woman on it
and finally you settle for aunt jemima
[Applause]
sad sad sad
i don't know man a lot of women here
tonight that's good
i like women my mother's a woman that
helps
you know what cool thing about women
women get to have platonic friends
he's my pal he's my bud
he's my platonic friend i love him like
a brother he's my bud my platonic friend
men don't have platonic friends okay we
just have women we haven't [ __ ] yet
as soon as i figure this out i'm in
there
i mean i mean we got some platonic
frisbee oh no i got something but they
all by accident
every platonic friend i got to show them
when i was trying to [ __ ]
i made a wrong turn somewhere
and ended up in the friend zone oh no
i'm in the friendzone
[Applause]
women keep platonic friends forever
why
because you never know
that's right they give her to
girlfriends every six months what
happened to pam she thinks she's cute
but they keep them platonic friends
forever why
because you never know
what happened to cow i can't hang with
her
but they keep them platonic friends
forever why
because you never know
you know what a platonic friend is to a
woman
it's like a dick in a glass case
[Applause]
in case of emergency break open glass
[Applause]
and fellas if your woman got platonic
friends that's who she'll be [ __ ]
when you mess up
one of them guys you ain't even thinking
about boys she'd be crying on the show
they can't believe this happened i'm so
glad you're here
[Applause]
that's right
it's gonna happen to you
you know the next man to [ __ ] your woman
you've met him he's been in your house
he's ate your food he's drank your wine
and he shall betray you
women got it good one thing i learned
about women guys never ask a woman how
many men she slept with
because you don't want to know
just be happy you're [ __ ] now
why you want to know you ain't
discovering [ __ ] you ain't putting a
flag nowhere
just be happy you're getting it now
why why why you want to know why why why
why
why
first of all no matter what she's saying
it's too much for you
no matter what she said she can go two
you'd be like two
who
who no no
i guess that's how you was raised
[Applause]
why you wanna make it wrong because
she's gonna lie women are lie about how
many guys she [ __ ] in court they don't
care
yeah i swear
yeah
and she says three that's 10.
so you got to give every woman like a
seven dick curve
that's more like three dicks to the
eighth power
and women y'all think you're slick y'all
ain't slick i know the game i'm watching
them for boy you ask the woman how many
guys she [ __ ] she's not gonna tell you
how many guys she [ __ ] she'll tell you
how many boyfriends she had because
women only count their boyfriends that's
right they don't count all those
miscellaneous dicks they had
[Applause]
[Music]
you know that guy they met at the club
the guy they [ __ ] from the club that
night oh that time they [ __ ] bobby brown
oh oh the guy they [ __ ] jamaica
that's another country it don't count
i thought we just talking about domestic
dick
that's right man and everybody talking
about gun control
gotta get rid of the guns [ __ ] that i
like guns
you got a gun you don't have to work out
i ain't working out i ain't jogging you
got pets i got texts
oh that's [ __ ] you don't need no gun
control you know what you need we need
some bullet control
we need to make we need to control the
bullets that's right i think all bullets
should cost five thousand dollars
five thousand dollars for a bullet you
know why because if a bullet costs five
thousand dollars there'll be no more
innocent bystanders
[Applause]
every time somebody gets shot at me like
damn he mustered this song
said they put 50 000 other bullets in
his head
and people would think before they
killed somebody if a bullet cost five
thousand dollars man i would blow your
[ __ ] head off if i could afford it
i'm gonna give me another job i'm gonna
start saving some money and you a dead
man
you better hope i can't get no bullets
on lay away
so even if you get shot by a straight
bullet you won't have to go to no doctor
to get it taken out whoever shot you and
take they pull it back
i believe you got my property
well i don't know women you know cool
thing about women i like about
a woman can fall in love with an ugly
man and admit it
show him off to all her friends in the
family be the ugliest guy in the world
and i'll be so proud of that ugly man to
hold his hand drag him around the place
introduce some people like this is kevin
i want you to be kevin i know he's not
that attractive
but he's good to me
men aren't like a man will never admit
to being in love with an ugly woman okay
we'll hide that [ __ ] to the depth we
ain't telling nobody see we could be
getting measured hey man i heard you get
married who told you that
don't spread the rumors all right you
know some of you women don't know if
they're ugly or not can't give
yourselves a test just a little test
don't be scared
yo if you've been over a guy's house
more than four times been [ __ ] every
time and haven't met anybody in the
house
he don't think you look that good
every time you go over all you see is
one room
but i gotta pee hold it in
i know that's me i know that's me man we
got one more this [ __ ] but won't take
out
oh that's me
that's right we got when we just [ __ ]
but won't take you out
for women y'all just as mean y'all got
men to let take out but you won't [ __ ]
these guys on dates right now ain't
getting [ __ ] so yeah i'm loosing her up
a little comedy she's like ain't nothing
that funny
that's right you can't ha-ha your way
into this
see that's the problem man we always
think we could buy sex like if i take it
here she give me something but by this
she give me something
nothing gets you nothing should a woman
know she's gonna [ __ ] you within the
first five minutes of meeting you women
know on the handshake they shaking hands
like i'mma [ __ ] him
i hope he don't say nothing stupid
that's right can't say nothing stupid
because women are all about the mood
that's right she's in the mood to shut
up let it happen
so if you say the wrong thing them pages
are coming up fast and you can win god
excuse me what you're saying
i'm telling you man no relationships
rough
easy to get in one
easy to get in a relationship hard to
maintain
you know it's like in marriage marriage
to me is not even a natural state to be
married for life anything for life just
promotes laziness okay that shouldn't be
for life man should be like a driver's
license five years and renew
[ __ ]
to love that fourth year who would be
good man
it's rough man it's hard man it's hard
to maintain a relationship man because
at some point no matter who it is at
some point you have heard everything
this person has to say
you heard it all you know what they get
ready to say before they even say it you
remember that time yeah i remember
they ever tell you yeah you told me
you have heard it all
and then what happens you stop talking
have a breakdown of communication
yet you gotta talk cause women love to
talk
women love to talk they are talking in
the olympics a man wouldn't stand a
chance
women love to talk
and feathers women don't want us to talk
to them
they just want us to set them up that's
all women want you to do if you're in a
relationship with a woman it's like
being in a comedy team and you're the
straight man just set her up feel the
lines all the women want you to do is go
how was your day that's all the [ __ ]
they want how was your day because how
was your day is a half hour conversation
to a woman it's a whole half hour and
you as the man the only thing you got to
do is go uh-huh
get out of here really get out of here i
told you that [ __ ] is crazy
but eventually hey women
you talk too much
you do you got to learn how to turn it
down a little bit you ever notice no man
comes straight home
no man comes straight home every man in
here has to go somewhere as soon as he
gets off work he got to go drink
something snort something shoot
something in his veins something to get
him ready for the talking that he's
about to hear
something that dead in his senses
and women it's not that you talk too
much you talk too much soon as we get in
the house
as soon as we get it done you ain't
gonna
let me get in the [ __ ] house
let me get my other foot in there [ __ ]
come on let me read the paper let me
have something to eat let me take a [ __ ]
damn
yeah i gotta go y'all be cool
but wait a minute
there's one exception
there's one exception
there's one
instance
where white people can say [ __ ]
and i'm gonna let it out tonight
i'm gonna let it out here in
johannesburg
the one time
that white people can say [ __ ] and
white people like this is what i paid
for
[Applause]
it's a [ __ ] great night now
the one time
white people could say [ __ ]
here goes listen closely
because i may never say this [ __ ] again
the one time white people could say
[ __ ] okay
if it's christmas eve
and it's between 4 30
and 4 49 in the morning
if you white
and you on your way to toys r us
to get your kid the last transformer dog
and right before you walk in the toys r
us some black person runs up beside you
smacks you in the head with a brick
knocks you to the ground stomps you in
the face kick such a quick ass
[ __ ] take that
[ __ ] take that your quick ass
[ __ ]
take that river dances on your head take
that your cracker ass [ __ ] ass
[ __ ] crack ass [ __ ] take
that quick ass
takes your money pisses on you
it runs away
if you white at that moment you can say
somebody stop that [ __ ]
matter of fact if you white and that
happens to you you could say [ __ ] for a
whole month
but you got to walk around with the
police report in your pocket
case any black people catch you saying
[ __ ] the police report will act as your
freedom payments
hey i heard you're saying [ __ ] let me
see your [ __ ] papers
give me the background shout out to
papers
christmas eve
[Applause]
you just made it [ __ ]
pissed on you
i hope they catch that [ __ ]